for anyone hoping that cyberpunk 2077's
big DLC expansion Phantom Liberty was
going to be a free add-on guess again as
CD projekt Red's Global PR director
radic Grabowski has confirmed that it
will have a price tag so much for
Liberty although I guess they did say it
was a phantom speaking to Games Radar
Grabowski confirmed that quote as for
the expansion's pricing we have not
revealed exact details yet but it will
be a paid one while we don't have any
specific pricing information for the DLC
expansions for The Witcher 3 Hearts of
stone and blood and wine cost ten
dollars and twenty dollars at their time
of release respectively with the latter
being a much bigger expansion than the
former like The Witcher 3 which has a
free next-gen update on the way in
December cyberpunk 2077 also received a
substantial amount of free DLC after
launch with the edge Runners update
providing a notable amount of free
Cosmetics weapons and even an extra
narrative thread something that will be
free is Call of Duty Warzone 2.0 which
recently revealed that its battle pass
is non-linear but we now have new
details on exactly how that will work
instead of having a linear pass of 100
tiers of unlockable items season 1 of
Warzone 2.0 reinvents the battle pass as
a multi-sector combat map the map has at
least 20 sectors with five items in each
sector players will unlock items using
earned battle token tier skips across
this map with the freedom to choose
their path and focus on the items they
want most the season 1 battle pass will
still include 23 tiers for players to
unlock which includes the victus XMR
sniper rifle and the basp southern
machine gun as this season's new
unlockable weapons Activision says it
will take place 15 token tier skips if
they head straight from the map's first
sector towards sectors A6 or A7 and 30
to unlock both weapons as for The
Season's new operator the pass into
juices zosa Zeus kalu as the operator
available within the premium tiers of
the past Zeus is an instant unlock when
purchasing the premium battle pass but
once players have unlocked all the
rewards and all the combat sectors
there's an additional Victory sector
with bonus rewards the battle pass costs
1400 total Cod points players can earn
400 free Cod points within the pass plus
a thousand more with premium pass and
victory sector allowing players to earn
back the Cod points spent purchasing
before pass along with the details of
the battle pass came the announcement of
DLC content for both Warzone 2.0 and
Modern Warfare 2 based on the seven
deadly sins the first of these is a
sloth bundle which includes the filovora
the sub-order of the animal sloth weapon
blueprint for the new sniper rifle in
the battle pass the bundle also includes
the Dissidia the Spanish word for
laziness operates a skin for Koenig and
the Deep sleep weapon blueprint for a
special shotgun that will knock down
enemies with Force Activision division
did not provide any images of the new
content Beyond this teaser image
Activision also didn't announce a
release date or a price for the sloth
bundle it will be followed by agreed
bundle later during season 1. the other
deadly sins are Pride lust Envy gluttony
and wrath but Activision didn't announce
any specific bundles themed around those
either what are your thoughts on Warzone
2.0's battle pass how much are you
willing to pay for cyberpunk DLC let us
know in the comments below and we'll see
you here tomorrow for more Gamespot news